So here's the answer. The result of the first expression
is always 0. No matter what string s is, we
always find s at the beginning of itself. So, if
we think of s as any string. If we search for
the string hello, in hello, well, we're going to find hello
at the beginning of hello, and that's position 0, that's
what fun will return, no matter what string s is,
the result of s.find s will always be 0. The result
of s.find passing in the string s, will only
be 0, if s started with the letter s. So
this is not always true. The third example always is
true, so here we have the string s, that's a
string with one character s, and what we're trying
to find in it is the string s. Well, we
find that at position 0. So that's the result find
we'll produce. The fourth one gets a little more tricky.
So here we're looking in the string s. We're looking for the
empty string. Remember the definition of find says it will give us
the first occurrence where that string appears. Well the empty string appears
in s. We don't actually see it, but it's there. We found
the empty string. There's no string there no matter what s is.
We can find the empty string in it, because we don't need
any string to find the empty string. So the result of s.find
passing an empty string, will always be 0, no matter what the
string s is. So the final one is also always
0. And the reason for this, is when we search
in s for the string s plus ! ! , well, no matter what s is. So even if it
was a string that already included ! ! . So
let's suppose that's the value of s. What we're trying
to find is now s plus ! ! . So
that's going to be what we had before, plus three more
exclamation points. Searching for that within the string s
will never be found. And we know it can't be
found because this string is actually longer than the
string s that we started with. So the result of
this expression is always going to be -1. That means
the string was never found. We add 1 to that,
we get 0. That's why this expression will always evaluate
to 0, no matter what the value of s is.